Following the smash-hit Skyfall, Daniel Craig
is back for his fourth outing as 007.
I'm Jan and this is 25 things you probably
didn't know about SPECTRE.
Spectre is the first time Aston Martin has
built a car specifically for a Bond movie.
The previous Aston Martins that have appeared
in the franchise were available for public
purchase.
The car Aston Martin built for Spectre is
the DB10, which is a concept car with a chassis
based on a modified V8 Vantage, and has a
top speed of 190mph.
A total of ten were built, eight of which
were used for filming, while the other two
were used for promotion.
As for the Jaguar C-X75 chasing Bond in Rome,
the car was so powerful that the stunt team
had to tone down its engine so the throttle
response was less aggressive.
It took 3 weeks to film the car chase through
the streets of Rome, which involved shutting
down key parts of the city while stunt performers
drove up to 100mph.
Although the chase involves only two cars
on screen, the filmmakers actually used 8
Aston Martins and 7 Jaguars to shoot the scene.
The filmmakers also shot for four days at
Rome's Museum of Roman Civilization, which
doubled as a cemetery.
The SPECTRE meeting in Rome was actually filmed
at Pinewood Studios on a set inspired by the
Royal Palace of Caserta, north of Naples.
And Oxfordshire's Blenheim Palace doubled
for the exterior of the building where that
meeting takes place.
The centrepiece of the movie's Day Of The
Dead parade is the Calavera Catrina skeleton,
which has a 10-metre wide hat and was inspired
by an etching by Mexican illustrator José
Guadalupe Posada.
It took 107 make-up artists three and a half
hours each day to get over 1,500 extras ready
for filming.
75 costumers designed 1,500 different outfits,
including 6 paper dresses which took 3 weeks
each to make, and a team of 20 people was
needed to clean and repair costumes overnight
for the next day's shoot.
Filming took place in three locations in Mexico
City: The Gran Hotel, the Plaza Tolsá, and
the city's main square, the Zócalo, where
Red Bull aerobatic pilot Chuck Aaron performed
a helicopter stunt, flying only 30 feet above
the movie's extras.
The toughest challenge of filming in Austria
was the lack of ice and snow due to the unseasonal
weather, which delayed preparations.
In fact, to cover the hillside, the production
had to make 400 tonnes of fake snow.
The exterior of the Hoffler Klinik was filmed
at the ICE-Q, a restaurant at the top of a
3000-metre mountain in Sölden, Austria.
However, scenes inside the Klinik were filmed
on a set built at Pinewood Studios.
The Austrian action sequence featuring an
aeroplane and Range Rovers, was especially
complex.
While only one airplane is seen on screen,
in reality special effects supervisor Chris
Corbould needed eight different planes to
pull off the stunt.
Two of the planes could fly, another two were
fitted to a wire rig, and four others were
just carcasses with skidoos inside them which
the stunt team used to control the planes.
For this action scene, the crew also built
10 sheds and a barn.
Eight of the sheds were bought in the local
mountains and rebuilt on set, while the remaining
sheds and barn were built from scratch using
20 miles of reclaimed wood.
The toughest location for Spectre's filmmakers
was Morocco.
As well as filming in the cities of Tangier
and Oujda, Spectre also shot outside Erfoud
in the Sahara desert, which meant that the
movie's locations department had to drive
out to let everyone within a 20-mile radius
know there were going to be loud explosions
during filming.
On the first day of the shoot in Erfoud, a
big sand storm, with winds up to 50 miles
an hour, meant there was no visibility so
the filmmakers had to halt production for
the whole afternoon.
As for the temperature during filming, the
average in Erfoud was over 110 degrees Fahrenheit,
and, on the hottest day, it was 122 degrees.
And as if it wasn't already hot enough in
the desert, the movie's special effects team
used more than 2,100 gallons of kerosene to
create what special effects supervisor Chris
Corbould, who's worked on 14 Bond movies,
says is the biggest explosion of his career.
According to producer Barbara Broccoli and
production designer Dennis Gassner, one of
the most difficult sets to get right was Bond's
London apartment because everyone has their
own idea of the kind of place 007 would live.
And because it says so much about Bond's character,
Daniel Craig was especially involved in the
design of that set.
The scheduling of the high-speed boat chase
was particularly complicated because of all
the events in London at the time, including
the General Election and Trooping the Colour.
The scene involved six night-time shoots and
low-flying helicopters, which meant the filmmakers
had to send 11,000 letters to notify residents
and businesses in the area.
But the biggest challenge was lighting the
River Thames, which involved lighting 17 arches
on 3 different bridges as well as 10 rooftops
along the banks of the river.
The filmmakers also worked with the House
of Commons, County Hall and The London Eye
to either change the colour of their lights
or make sure they had their lights on or off,
as needed.
Each night-time shoot involved a location
team of nearly 200 people, from security to
traffic management.
Now, let me know in the comments below, which
actor do YOU think is the best Bond and why?
And who would you like to be the next Bond
after Daniel Craig?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for loads more things you didn't know, as
well as movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!